by some measures our economy is doing
great food fuel everything costs too
much both of these candidates are kind
of right leading into the midterm
elections inflation is high the highest
in the last 40 years and gas prices are
volatile though they've come down
recently there's still a lot of
uncertainty about where they're going
next but then again there's incredibly
low unemployment just look at the number
of job openings right now things are
expensive but people are working yet
most economists pulled by The Wall
Street Journal believe the US is headed
towards a recession in the next year the
economy is always a big deal in any
election I mean as James Carville once
famously coined the term in 1992 it's
the economy stupid this year is
obviously a year where we're seeing a
lot of interest a lot of intensity and
debate about the economy here's how the
economy actually is doing and why it
matters for the November midterms I
can't tell you how many times I've seen
gas pumps and grocery store aisles in
political ads this year inflation is one
of the big economic measures you can
feel personally and I feel the pain too
because I do the grocery shopping and
not just at the grocery store although
the price of food has gone up more than
most things if you look at median weekly
earnings people are making less than
they were during the last election if
adjusted for inflation inflation is sort
of taking a bite out of you know what
otherwise would be a fairly strong and
robust economy coming out of the
pandemic Republicans are largely blaming
Biden's Reckless spending trillions in
spending out of control spending while
Democrats point out the supply chain is
more microchipped here in America to get
the supply chain moving again we'll beat
inflation one chip at a time there's a
lot of reasons for why inflation is at
this super high level you know it has to
do with Global Supply chains it has to
do with the pandemic it has to do do
with Energy prices you know the
situation in Ukraine all of that has
contributed to astronomical price
increases and so both parties are trying
to point to certain aspects of of that
bigger formula another place voters have
felt the economic pressure if you're fed
up every time you fill up let's take a
closer look at that gas price chart here
is where the Russian invasion of Ukraine
began experts largely blamed that war
for the initial increase but it stayed
high for a number of reasons Republicans
blame our energy production has been
crippled they've cratered our domestic
energy production while Democrats blame
oil companies gouging us at the pump
price gouging by Big Oil both sides have
some points but there's no sort of easy
answer analysts pointed things beyond
the Biden administration's control like
maintenance ad refineries some of these
things just have to do with you know
Global Supply chains coming out of the
pandemic we're just obviously in a
really weird
time for the economy Americans
frustration over Rising prices show up
in arguably the most important factor
going into the election how people feel
this is the consumer sentiment index it
measures how optimistic or pessimistic
people are feeling about the economy in
the last 40 years every time the
president's party has lost a large
number of seats in the midterms it was
after a period where Americans felt
pessimistic about the economy you never
want voters to be in a grumpy mood when
you're the party in power it's easier
for them to sort of cast that ballot in
opposition and right now people feel
worse about the economy than they even
did during the Great Recession even
though there are far fewer people filing
unemployment claims today than there
were during that recession there are
also more jobs being added today than
even during the Great recessions
recovery
by these measures the economy is good
but where people feel the economy the
most the grocery store and the gas
station it's not for voters they're
definitely hearing you know the blame
game from both sides and ultimately for
them it's going to come down who which
party do you think has the best chance
of fixing it
[Music]